[Musique]
évacuer les Canadiens coincés dans un
Soudan secoué par de violents
affrontements appuyez l'Ukraine dans sa
lutte contre la Russie calmer les
tensions en Haïti quand une crise
survient dans le monde les regards ici
se tournent vers Mélanie Joly la
ministre des Affaires étrangères celle
qui a le mandat de défendre la
perspective et les intérêts canadiens
sur les tribunes internationales
a-t-elle réussi à imposer la voix du
Canada dans le monde j'ai rencontré la
ministre jolie au quartier général des
affaires étrangères à Ottawa
Mélaine jolie bonjour
commençons par commençons par parler du
Soudan on a on a évacué des Canadiens
là-bas
vous les voyez durer combien de temps
ces évacuations mais en fait jusqu'à
temps que ça soit possible pour nous et
nos forces armées de sortir des
Canadiens de plus en plus on voit qu'on
est en mesure justement d'en sortir on a
participé à un effort international
depuis le jour 1 la crise donc on était
capable de travailler avec la France
avec l'Allemagne avec le Royaume-Uni
pour sortir plusieurs les Canadiens qui
étaient déjà là et là on était capable
aussi de faire atterrir de nos avions et
donc présentement chaque personne qui
est au soudain qui qui a un problème et
qui lève la main on est en contact avec
cette personne là et le but c'est qu'il
puisse être
dans le fond transporté à un endroit à
l'extérieur qui est sécuritaire il y a
des gens qui ont dit
pourquoi ça brille tant il y avait des
avions d'autres pays qui étaient là
cartoon qui ramassa des gens des
Canadiens qui sont montés à bord des
appareils là les nôtres
attestationnelles Djibouti puis on nous
disait bah c'est difficile ça nous prend
de la place à l'aéroport pourquoi ça a
pas été organisé plus rapidement
premièrement il y en a pas perdu du
temps parce que dès le jour 1 on a
commencé à sortir des gens le premier
pays
des avions donc je pense vraiment pas
qu'on a perdu du temps on a 200 soldats
qui sont allés pour aussi aider les
forces britanniques à sécuriser
l'aéroport et puis on va continuer nos
pays dont on parle beaucoup dont vous
parlez beaucoup c'est Haïti ou la
situation
ne s'améliore et la semaine dernière
il y a des citoyens qui ont pris sur eux
de capturer des gens qui avaient été qui
étaient sous le contrôle de la police
nationale haïtienne de les lyncher
essentiellement sur la place publique
vous misez sur la police nationale
haïtienne depuis le début
comment ça se fait qu'est-ce qui
fonctionne pas
encore une fois
la situation en Haïti c'est détériori
encore plus le nombre de meurtugmenter
le nombre de kidnapping a augmenté
encore une fois l'ONU dans son rapport
la semaine dernière a dit maintenant ce
qui se passe en Haïti c'est l'équivalent
d'une zone de guerre donc
la gestion la plus respectée en Haïti
c'est la police nationale haïtienne
pendant les années le Canada aidé à
former les policiers
là dessus mais ça fonctionne pas
une population de 11 millions de
personnes qui est plus grande que le
Québec donc il y a un manque de
policiers il y a un manque d'expertise
et nous on travaille là-dessus le Canada
est encore est toujours le leader sur la
question d'Haïti ça sera encore le cas
mais bien entendu le but c'est de faire
en sorte de de renforcer la capacité
parce que c'est la meilleure façon
on dirait que le feu est prêt à la
résidence mais en forme des pompiers
mais je pense que on doit certainement
renforcer la police nationale haïtienne
je pense c'est important aussi que l'ONU
travaille à trouver des solutions nous
on va être là pour aider le mieux le
problème avec l'ONU présentement de
sécurité est paralysé parce que la Chine
est particulièrement la Russie le bloc
toute forme de travail qui peut être
fait via le Conseil de sécurité alors
notre objectif c'est de continuer à
travailler avec plusieurs partenaires de
la région pour trouver une solution
politique et bien entendu participer aux
efforts de l'ONU pour justement en
arriver à une solution est-ce que ce
pays-là peut retrouver une stabilité
sans intervention extérieure militaire
ou paramilitaire ou d'une intervention
dirigée par le nu dirigé par un autre
pays est-ce que est-ce que on peut
retrouver un semblant de stabilité sans
ça ce pays-là besoin sécuritaire puis on
peut pas faire en sorte de refaire
encore et toujours la même solution
c'est à dire une intervention de la part
de l'ONU et puis à profiter ça ne
fonctionne pas donc notre objectif c'est
de renforcer les capacités et trouver
des solutions paries pour les Haïtiens
c'est pour ça qu'on prend une approche
de la du renforcement de la police
nationale haïtienne c'est la Russie qui
préside le Conseil de sécurité
qui a présidé deux réunions cette
semaine qui est tenu un discours
évidemment qui va un peu à l'encontre de
ce que tout ce qui est tout ce qui était
dit par rapport à l'Ukraine par rapport
à la position russe quand vous regardez
ça vous de l'extérieur ça vous dit quoi
sur le nu c'est sûr que quand on regarde
ça regarde la preuve qui va au Conseil
de sécurité
et qui nous met en visage je sais pas
comment servir la vraie va arriver à se
regarder dans le miroir mais une chose
est sûre c'est que la Russie essaye de
déchirer le papier lequel les règles de
la Charte des Nations Unies
sont écrites c'est un problème à partir
du moment où la Russie a décidé
d'envahir l'Ukraine ils ont été en total
violation de la Charte des Nations Unies
et nous mais il faut faire en sorte de
les rendre imputables est-ce que ça
complique les choses quand on quand vous
entendez par un discours mener en pleine
en plein centre-ville de New York le nu
et que l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale voit les choses d'une
autre façon
je pense que c'est bien que l'ensemble
de la communauté internationale se
rallie à la question de la protection du
territoire et de la souveraineté du
crâne je pense que c'est important
maintenant il y a beaucoup de pays dans
le monde qui veulent que certaines
règles qui nous dirigent depuis 75 ans
qui ont assuré notre stabilité que ces
règles-là soient
modifiées parce que ce sont des pays qui
sont des régimes plus autoritaires puis
qui veulent faire en sorte d'avoir leur
propre sphère d'influence et leur propre
contrôle peu importe les Nations Unies
nous sommes jamais l'accepter
la Chine la Russie etc puis plusieurs
pays qui sont dans une situation très
difficile qui font face à une crise de
la dette dans leur propre pays à cause
de la pandémie à cause dans le fond des
impacts des changements climatiques donc
ça ça fait en sorte que eux ils croient
dans la Nations Unies mais ils veulent
aussi plus d'aide puis il nous regarde
nous pays de G7 pour qu'on en fasse plus
et une des grandes discussions que lui
présente dans le nouveau international
c'est la réforme du financement dans le
fond des de la Banque mondiale des
systèmes financier international pour
les aider à être capable de gérer leurs
crises parce que parce que parce que
quand vous le faites pas ce vide là est
occupé par la Chine la Russie c'est ça
exactement parce que présentement il y a
une garde influence certainement en
Afrique certainement en Amérique latine
certainement aussi en Asie et nous notre
rôle c'est d'être ce pays qui dans la
main pour aider qui est capable d'amener
les préoccupations de plusieurs pays et
de leur offrir la plateforme nécessaire
pour exprimer ce point de vue là ça fait
un an et demi que vous êtes le chef de
canadienne c'est comme ça qu'on
l'appelle vous êtes la cinquième
ministre de votre gouvernement
depuis arrivé au pouvoir des libéraux en
il y avait beaucoup de critiques à
l'écart à l'égard de la politique des
Affaires étrangères du gouvernement vous
aviez entamé une révision l'année
dernière elle est où cette révision ça
va bien j'aurais au cours des prochaines
semaines plus d'informations vous donner
sur la réforme comment on peut améliorer
dans le fond la façon dont notre
diplomatie fonctionne on sait où mais en
fait on reconnaît qu'il y a certainement
des enjeux mais en même temps que c'est
nécessaire de s'adapter à la réalité
d'aujourd'hui qui est essentiellement
que les crises sont plus fréquentes
qu'il y a une croissance des de
l'instabilité que aussi le Canada doit
être présent dans les organisations
internationales pour défendre notre
point de vue défendre le point de vue de
nos alliés parce que certainement la
Russie la Chine sont là pour tenter de
modifier et parfois de d'aller en
contradiction avec les règles du jeu qui
sont en place ça se traduit comment
concrètement donne-moi un exemple de
quelque chose que pourrait faire le
Canada qui qui vous amènerait dans cette
direction là je pense que on a annoncé
au mois de juin dernier qu'on ouvrait 8
nouvelles ambassades dans le monde ça
c'est un exemple de réengagement
sur le terrain donc on ouvre au Rwanda
on va voir un siège aussi à l'Union
africaine d'observateur une nouvelle
ambassade en Lituanie nouvelle ambassade
en Estonie nouvelle ambassade en Arménie
à une nouvelle ambassade en Slovaquie et
essentiellement on voit que c'est en
Afrique et aussi proche de la Russie
dans le fond dans les pays qui sont
voisins en même temps je suis arrivée
avec une stratégie de pacifique qui est
la plus grande stratégie en 30 ans parce
que c'est là où l'avenir de la planète
se décide et tout ce qui va se passer en
indopacifique en Asie va avoir un impact
chez nous à la maison
petite question un peu plus politique en
terminant je suis Trudeau a déjà dit
qu'il serait là au prochain scrutin mais
à chaque fois qu'on parle de la
succession de Monsieur Trudeau votre nom
bondit dans la pile pourquoi mais moi je
suis j'ai toujours été très loyale à
Monsieur Trudeau c'est lui qui m'a amené
en politique fédérale je pense qu'il
fait un très bon boulot il a toute ma
confiance et toute mon appui et puis du
reste on verra qu'est-ce que la vie
[Musique]
me réserve j'aimerais bien être maman
j'en ai souvent parlé et qu'on verra